23 million pounds to end hiv in this
country by 2030 is that the right
approach do you think
well i think that we can do that
if you look at places of high prevalence
at like brighton we had 20
or so
hiv diagnosis this year but only four of
them were newly infected the rest were
people who have had it for over a year
or longer and just weren't getting
tested so this real push to make sure
that we test and in brighton and
manchester and a few other areas we're
going to do opt-out testing now so when
you get your bloods done we'll
automatically screen it for hiv we can
really start to push to get um
no more infections in this country and
start to end the disease but we only do
that by also starting to end stigma and
as your report said the the fastest
growing group of people for diagnostic
infections are actually women at the
moment so we need to make sure that
we're reaching out to all parts and all
sections of our society because we
really can do this it is in our grasp
it's taken 40 years but isn't it amazing
that human endeavor has meant that
within 40 years we might be able to
within 50 years we might be able to
actually eradicate this disease in
britain first of all and then around the
world and for those people in this
country who are identified as hiv
positive
am i right in saying now medical
treatment is such that you know you can
live with it and live a normal life it's
not
if it's identified it's not the deadly
disease that we will remember from the
80s and 90s
exactly i mean i'm i've been hiv
positive now for 10 years i'm on
treatment i take one pill a day just
before i go to bed and when they test my
blood it's undetectable it means the
test can't even detect hiv there if i
stop taking the pill it might come back
but actually that undetectable means i
can't pass it on which is vitally
important for if we're going to stop
this disease but it also means apart
from um you know kind of my usual
activities uh you know kind of that we
all do that might limit our lives you
know kind of over drinking and smoking
or whatever that people do i will live
as long as anyone else and what about
the rest of the world away from the rich
world i mean are
is that sort of treatment that sort of
maintenance treatment available
uh in the places where hiv positivity is
high you know for example in in africa
well unfortunately in africa hiv and
aids is still the biggest killer for
adolescent girls so you know there's a
stark difference of course and we need
to roll these medications out i mean
i've been on trips where um they will
have part of the medication but not the
whole amount of medication
but in places like africa it's not just
about dealing with hiv it's dealing with
health in a holistic way because if you
haven't got that the centers health
centers across the country you haven't
got places where people can get tested
where people can pick up their medicine
so it's not just about attacking hiv
alone it's about tackling health
issues in those countries and then it
has advantages for tb malaria hiv all
those diseases can be started to be
tackled but
this plan is primarily about in the uk
how we can try and eradicate it in less
than 10 years how we can make sure we
stack tackle the stigma internal stigma
of people that might have it that means
that they then don't get treated or
tested but also the societal stigma in
terms of making sure that we they know
and everyone knows that if you are on
treatment you're undetectable if you're
undetectable you can't pass it on and
you live that life and that will make
the real difference and if we can show
that we can do it here in the richer
countries then the focus will need to
pass on to us helping the poorer
countries do that as well now it is
world aids day that's your ribbon you're
wearing in your lapel
and in advance of that uh joe biden has
made a significant statement uh saying
that the united states wishes to
concentrate
on this disease amongst other causes uh
president trump of course wouldn't talk
about aids for the four years he was in
the white house how significant is that
change do you think in terms of the
fight against aids globally
look it is really significant the u.s
it is a country that oscillates between
one extreme and another very often but i
remember when i was first diagnosed to
get into the usa you either had to deny
your diagnosis or you weren't allowed to
go
because there was an absolute ban that's
within the last 10 years we have obama
lifted that trump tried to reverse some
of those things and biden is setting a
path i hope where we will see the u.s
with european countries pushing to
eradicate this disease and then to
support the rest of the world to do it
but if you don't talk about these things
people don't get tested people don't
know about it and ignorance now is the
killer it's not the disease itself but
it's the lack of knowledge
lloyd russell mile thank you very much
indeed for joining us on world aids day